[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to a
brand-new Code Geass video in this video
we're going to be talking about how many
of the Geass powers in Code Geass
including the lucious power to control
people and make them do what he wants
appear to be based and directly inspired
by spells in the iconic role-playing
game Dungeons and Dragons one of the
reasons that I still have YouTube as a
platform is that I personally have never
played Dungeons and Dragons so I never
would have known about this connection
between Dungeons and Dragons and Code
Geass if find a bear didn't leave a
comment on one of our Code Geass videos
pointing out that a spell in Dungeons
and Dragons called Geass but spelled
with one s instead of two is very
similar to the power that Lelouch has in
code geass so a huge thank you to find a
bear for inspiring this video and a big
thank you as well to divinity from our
discord server for pointing out that a
whole bunch of other Geass powers other
than the lucious power also correspond
to spells in Dungeons and Dragons but
more on that a little later if you are
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
and click down notification bell for
more code geass theory and news videos
and if you want to chat with us on a
daily basis you can join our discord
server the link is in the description
now we know that Irish mythology Aggies
is an obligation or prohibition similar
to being under a vow or a spell Aggies
can be compared with a curse or
paradoxically a gift if someone under
Aggies that violates the Associated
taboo the in fracture will suffer
dishonor or even death on the other hand
the observing of one's géza is believed
to bring power often it is women who
plays GISA upon men in some cases the
woman turns out to be a goddess or other
type of magical creature which of course
reminds us of c2s connection to Lelouch
in Dungeons and Dragons the spell called
geese spelled with one s or also known
as quest was an enchantment spell that
commanded any subject
to undertake a task or suffer possibly
fatal pain and thickness arcane spell
casters and bards usually called the
spell Geass while divine spell casters
refer to it as quest and of course we
are already seeing huge similarities
between relishes Geass power to command
individuals to do whatever he wants and
a spell called Geass which also compels
creatures to do whatever the user wants
and the penalty for not doing so can be
deadly
the Geass spell can be used to coerce a
creature to perform a task or restrain a
creature from some sort of action the
casting time is 10 minutes 24 seconds
for the older version and could not be
willfully resisted the subject has to be
alive conscious intelligent enough to
understand the instructions and under
control of their own mind the
instructions have to be given in a
language understood by the subject and
have to have clear conditions to be met
for the Geass or quest to be fulfilled
if the task was left open ended without
an end condition the spell lasted for
one day per experience level of the
caster otherwise the spell asset until
the task was complete regardless of how
long it took now the really interesting
thing here for me is that in Dungeons
and Dragons the individual that you are
using this spell on has to be conscious
has to understand the language in which
you are speaking because this spell also
works on a mental basis on a
consciousness basis just like Geass does
in the world of Code Geass in fact iñaki
to the exiled it is established that for
a guest power to work the person you are
using it on has to understand what you
are commanding them to do and because of
this Akito from a key to the Exile did
not die when his brother commanded him
to because he was too young to
understand the concept of death so in
this sense the Geass spell and Geass
power appeared to work on the same
principle it works on a mental level and
the person you are using it on
has to understand what you are
commanding them to do however there is a
major difference in Dungeons & Dragons
the Geass spell cannot be used to
command anyone to commit suicide however
we know that in Code Geass Lelouch can
use his power to command people to
commit suicide and of course shin Hyuga
shang Iquitos brother can do the same
thing as well the other really
interesting thing about the Geass spell
is that the only way to remove this
spell in the older version of Dungeons &
Dragons from the subject was with a wish
a limited wish or a miracle which of
course reminds us of situ trying to have
her wish fulfilled as part of her
contract with Lelouch from what I was
able to gather the Geass spell was
introduced to Dungeons & Dragons way
back in the first edition in 1978 so 30
years before Code Geass initially aired
and while some rules about the Geass
spell have changed over the years in
general the concept has remained
relatively similar and while this one
Dungeons & Dragons spell by the name of
Geass with one s that is very similar to
Lelouch is Geass power is interesting on
its own I was able to learn thanks to
the help of divinity from our discord
server that there are a whole bunch of
other Geass powers that seem to
correspond directly or very closely to
other spells in Dungeons & Dragons I
will talk about all of those now and
thanks again to divinity for helping me
out with this as I said I have not
played Dungeons and Dragons so I never
would have been able to figure this out
without his and find a bear cell and if
you want to learn more about Dungeons &
Dragons and I have to say it does sound
interesting now that I've done all this
research on the game you can contact
divinity on Twitter I will leave the
link in the description starting things
off with mouths Geass whose power is
equivalent to the spell known as detect
thoughts although mouse power is
actually stronger than this spell in the
game for the duration of this spell you
can read the thoughts of certain
creatures when you cast a spell and as
your action on each turn until the spell
ends you can focus your mind on any one
creature that you can see within 30 feet
of you then we have Charles who's gay
is equivalent to the spell known as
modified memory with modify memory you
can attempt to reshape another creatures
memories while this charm lasts you can
affect the targets memory of an event
that it experienced within the last 24
hours
and that lasted no more than 10 minutes
you can permanently eliminate all memory
of the event allow the target to recall
the event with perfect clarity and
exacting detail change its memory of the
detail of the event or create a memory
of some other event c2s Geass is
equivalent to the spell known as charmed
person but modified with charm person
you attempt to charm a humanoid you can
see within range it must make a wisdom
saving throw and does so with advantage
if you are your companions are fighting
it if it fails it is charmed by you
until the spell ends or until you or
your companions do something harmful to
it at higher levels when you cast this
spell using a spell slot of second level
or higher you can target one additional
creature for each slot level above the
first they must be within 30 feet of
each other when you target them bismarck
Wallops teams Geass power is equivalent
to the foresight spell and it is one of
the higher rank spells in Dungeons and
Dragons due to its potency with
foresight you touch a willing creature
and bestow a limited ability to see into
the immediate future for the duration of
this spell the target can't be surprised
and has advantage of attack rolls
ability checks and saving throws
additionally other creatures have a
disadvantage on attack rolls against the
target for the duration of this spell
Rollo's Geass power is equivalent to the
spell known as time stop with time stop
you briefly stop the flow of time for
everyone but yourself no time passes for
other creatures while you take one v 4 +
1 turns in a row during which you can
use actions and move as normal this
spell ends if one of the actions you use
during this period or any effect that
you create during this period effect a
creature other than you or an object
being worn or carried by someone
other than yourself in addition the
spell and if you move to a place more
than 1,000 feet from the location where
you cast it so this spell just like
Rolo's kiosks has both time and range
restrictions Marion's Geass has an
equivalent in Dungeons & Dragons as well
and this spell is known as life force
exchange with life force exchange the
spell permanently switches the light
forces of two creatures one of which may
be you within sixty yards both
recipients must be within range at the
time the spell is completed or it fails
automatically and this is just like
Merion having to use her Geass power on
Anya because Anya was in the same room
as Mari on when she got shot in the
event of a successful transfer both life
forces retain all their original mental
abilities and behavioral patterns
although their physical abilities are
limited or possibly enhanced by their
new forms even the power of characters
from the Code Geass manga appears to be
inspired by spells from Dungeons &
Dragons the power of Orpheus from Arthur
reflection has an equivalent in Dungeons
& Dragons known as the sky self and this
is actually a low-level parlor trick
spell in the game with the sky self you
can make yourself including your
clothing armor weapons and other
belongings on your person look different
until the spell ends or until you can
use at an action to dismiss it you can
see one foot shorter or taller and can
appear thin fat or in-between you can't
change your body type so you must adopt
a form that has the same basic
arrangement of limbs otherwise the
extent of the illusion is up to you the
power of chloral and Franck from the
odds reflection manga is equivalent to
the Geass spelled just like Lelouch the
difference is that she has to call out
the person's real name but for
controlling them and Maribel Mel
Britannia Geass is an enhanced version
or higher version of the same Geass
spell because Mary Belle is able to have
complete control over a person's body
total thompson's Geass is just like
Charles's Geass modify memories
but it is the weakest version of it as
it can only erase a particular memory
the Dungeons & Dragons equivalent of the
Shin Hyuga Chang Geass is known as power
word kill you utter a word of power that
can compel one creature you can see
within range to die instantly if the
creature you choose has 100 hit points
or fewer it dies otherwise the spell has
no effect Layla's Geass from Akito the
exiled is equivalent to the mightiest
mortal spell known as wish wish is the
mightiest spell a mortal creature can
cast and by simply speaking aloud you
can alter the very foundations of
reality in accordance with your desires
finally Jeremiah's Geass Chancellor is
similar to two different spells
counterspell and the spell magic counter
spell attempts to interrupt a creature
in the process of casting a spell and if
successful the creature spell fails and
has no effect the spell magic and the
current spell on one creature object or
magical effect within range what all of
these spells have in common is that they
can be created by just one class on
arcane type caster or the wizard and
with the appropriate build you can
actually make yourself something like a
code user in the world of Dungeons and
Dragons
a sufficiently powerful wizard can
eventually undergo a ritual that kills
them but then they come back to life as
an immortal being or Lynch with their
memories and they can even become a
patron and give power to mortals and
allow them to use spells like Geass so
even the code user appears to have an
equivalent in the world of Dungeons and
Dragons
finally the newer gods in Dungeons &
Dragons come into existence once enough
people believe in them much like the
collective unconscious in seas world is
an artificial God that pools
consciousness of people together after
they die so yeah I thought this was
extremely interesting while doing this
research to find that there are so many
similarities between the spells in
Dungeons & Dragons and the world of
Dungeons & dry
and of course Geass power and the world
of Code Geass thanks again to find a
bear and divinity for their health and
let me know what you think down in the
comments below
are all of these similarities are
coincidence or the dungeons and dragons
directly inspire Code Geass as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]